le plus important chantier du monde se
trouve à paris
au rond-point de la défense la france
qui est toujours si critiquer et qui
d'autre part mais sans cesse en valeur
les belles réalisations de l'étranger
oublie généralement de montrer les
belles réalisations françaises
et c'est pour les montrer que nous
sommes venus interviewer aujourd'hui le
président prouveront et lui demandait de
nous présenter son chantier
monsieur le président pourriez vous nous
dire ce que représente cette masse
énorme de béton armé cette masse énorme
de béton armé représente essentiellement
l'acte de foi de l'industrie française
en la valeur et la qualité de ses
fabrications
il fallait à la france ce qu'ils avaient
ce que les étrangers possèdent le moyen
de montrer leur production industrielle
nous n'avions rien de digne pour abriter
nos techniques qui sont exceptionnelles
et qui aujourd'hui représente dans le
monde la meilleure des qualités aussi
nous avons voulu leur fabriquer cet
écrin qui j'espère sera digne d'elle
ce sera le musée de l'industrie
française ce sera le musée permanent
l'industrie france et combien coûte
cette immense bâtiment environ trois
milliards et demi et quels sont les
architectes kg conçu à trois très grands
architectes et 3 très grand ami
messieurs camelot airbus et demailly
assisté d'ailleurs par des ingénieurs
exceptionnel dans des skis qui a conçu
la technique même du bâtiment
lacombe qui était son assistant constant
et que j'espère je vous présenterai tout
à l'heure et mühleberg be à surveiller
qui continue de faire marcher le
chantier avec une constance admirable
merci aux présidents d'un arrière fou ce
qu'on vous doit déjà le palais de
l'unesco place qu'emploie et je voudrais
que vous nous présentiez votre nouvel
enfant donnez nous quelques schiste et
surtout quelques images qui nous fera
comprendre l'importance de cette
réalisation
et bien ce ce palais fait cent mille
mètres carrés de surface construite et
il représente à peu près par un pont au
grand palais il représente une surface
d'exposition de plus de deux fois le
grand prenait d'autre part ce qui est
assez caractéristique c'est la
couverture du bâtiment puisque
l'ensemble de la construction qui fait à
peu près au sol qui représente 3 ha
repose sur trois points
ces trois points étant distant disposés
sur suivant un triangle équilatéral la
distance de ces points étant de 220 m
c'est à dire pour trouver l'image ça
représente la place de la concorde sur
la façade de gabriel porté sur deux
points le troisième point et tente à la
madeleine et la hauteur de ce bâtiment
la hauteur de ce bâtiment est de 50
mètres c'est à dire qu'on pourrait il
mettre dessous sous la coupole sous la
voûte on pourrait mettre l'arc de
triomphe et il sera terminé quand il
sera terminé dans quinze mois environ
jon maïs on vous doit déjà la
reconstruction du fort de tulou et je
voudrais vous demander de nous présenter
le visage de ce centre national des
industries et technique vous avez le
plan sous le bras mais vous de le
montrer bon avant tout je voudrais
rectifier mais gérard commises par mon
camarade dire plus je ferai plus jeune
chimiste que lui et c'est dans dix mois
en septembre prochain que nous aurons
notre première manifestation dans
partie basse du palais et on vous donne
déjà rendez vous pendant dix mois alors
ce palais va se trouver très sur le haut
lieu n'est ce pas du grand tracé de
paris saint germain dont nous parlera
tout à l'heure notre camarade camelot
nous nous trouvons donc voici la scène
qui est ici nous nous trouvons à l'heure
actuelle au rond-point de la défense qui
sur ce plan est déjà modifié pour
l'aménagement de tout le secteur des
circulations du lieu le palais de la
mécanique s'ouvrira largement sur un
parvis qui enjambera le grand axe que je
viens de nommer et de l'autre côté de ce
palais asymétriquement à grand volume
qui est symbolisée sur le dessin par une
tour de 200 mètres de hauteur viendra
équilibrer la forme basse de notre
palais 200 m dos mais qui logera dans
cette tour eh bien il c'est un building
complexe dans lequel se trouvera un
grand appel de qualité internationale
les services
du centre de la mécanique et une autre
branche du building sera affecté à une
autre compagnie le président pouvons
nous est tout à l'heure qu'il était fier
de ses deux jeunes ingénieurs et je n'ai
pas voulu terminer cette visite de
chantier sans vous présenter ces deux
phoenix sur le président vous pourriez
vous nous le présenter les uns et les
autres ont ce n'est pas que 2 phoenix
d'ailleurs que je vais vous présenter
nous sommes fiers dans l'industrie
française d'avoir des jeunes qui savent
montrer au monde que les jeunes français
malgré tout ce qu'ont dit nos complexes
d'infériorité est faux et que voici ici
lacombe dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure que l'ingénieur en chef chef du
bureau d'études et qui a mené à bien
sous les ordres des clients dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et qui n'est pas
ici toute cette étude extraordinaire
devant laquelle le monde entier
technique s'incline avec l âge
en 16 ans c'est votre premier grand
chantier rouge en effet déjà de grands
mais jamais aussi grand vous êtes
responsable de toutes les études n
toutes les études tous les dessins des
18 cents dessins qui sont sortis des
presses autour d'études où on a fait un
travail d'équipé entre eugène cession à
peu près une dizaine d'ingénieurs sous
mes ordres qui je crois avons fait du
mont pareils monsieur hiver 128 milles
vers lui et l'ingénieur chargé de
l'exécution du chantier
il a à connaître de tous les dessins et
les responsables de leur exécution ce
qui n'est pas non plus une mince tâche
combien d'ouvriers sont aux ordres il ya
350 ouvriers à laver france et 40
ouvriers un autre usine de nanterre et
vous avez qu à l'âge de 34 ans sur le
premier grand chantier ainsi non on
n'est déjà fait plusieurs le calmar
exemple mais notamment les hangars de
marignane et le pont de la voulte sur le
rhône je crois qu'on ne peut pas achevé
sans présenter le ceba l'asie qui est
lui or le grand responsable puis c'est
moi qui coordonne l'activité de ses
jeunes poulains c'est pas une tâche
tellement facile tout compte fait mais
enfin ils sont tellement plein de
dynamisme que on leur pardonne un tas de
choses et quantifie ça marche très bien
et la joie y est vous je ne vous la
rumba une trentaine d'années enfin
son plein de sang plein de sève et il
faut un grand honneur industrie français
à grandir ce couac c'est donc un âge où
je ne fais plus d'études techniques je
me contente de les coordonner
et c'est une tâche passionnante et je
dois dire que je suis très heureux de
voir les violentes cette qualité ce
n'est pas seulement le plus grand
chantier du monde mais c'est aussi le
plus jeune champion du monde est
également le plus jeune sentiers du
monde ce qui montre que la france mon
dieu c'est faire de grandes choses quand
elle s'adresse à ses élites marchante et
ces jeunes élites marchera merci
monsieur